this is a production of Cornell
University good thank you all so much
for the chance to be here really fun
both the conversations i've had over the
last two days I also just came to wander
around campus again about 15 years since
I first showed up here so we had a
conversation at dinner last night about
some of the digital AG stuff that is
going on here at Cornell so I want to
highlight before I get into my talk this
is my research group as of last summer
at University of nebraska-lincoln but a
lot of the stuff I'm going to tell you
about is only possible because we were
collaborating with folks like you fungo
who's a biological systems engineer and
you moe and you hyung who are both
statisticians at University of Nebraska
so it's really being able to work with
folks across different disciplines that
lets us do really really cool stuff that
to me seems extraordinarily hard and to
them it's quite easy and then we get to
also brandy Sigmund who is an actual
developmental geneticist which is fun so
I'm going to start with a sort of broad
question then we're going to move into
some phenomics then into some
quantitative genetics can come back to
sort of broad conceptual stuff so now
for our question here which is you know
I think one of the central questions of
all genetics is how do we find which
Janee which genes determine the
characteristics of maize or any organism
and I like to bring this up because I
want you to think about you know what
actually we mean when we say the word
gene so when I first started out in grad
school the maize genome had just come
out there about 32,000 gene models then
there was a revision that went up from
about 32,000 to about 40,000 another
revision it went up for about 60,000 so
about the time that I got my own lab we
were adding about 5,000 genes to the
genome every year now if it takes one
grad student five years to characterize
one gene you can see that just from a is
we would need about 25,000 graduate
students and about 1.25 billion dollars
a year in funding to keep up now
obviously this would not be sustainable
for a lot of reasons working you know
government policy and NSF and all that
it also is clearly not what's happening
maize was not adding a lot of new genes
to the genome what was half
we were using different criteria and had
different evidence for what constitutes
a gene model so if you go into Google
Scholar and you type in what is a gene
you will find this review from Oh more
than a decade ago now where they posed
this very complicated and almost
legalistic definition of what a gene is
and I will say that men had mentioned
I've worked with some companies and
there's some very good things about that
one of the negative things is you spend
a lot of time talking to lawyers about
IP law and organizational law and you
know who's going to have control of
which part of the company if one of the
partners gets divorced
especially the partners who aren't
married yet so it feels like a lot of
pressure to have to be divorced before
you gonna anyway so I would say that
this is a definition only a lawyer could
be happy with so if you go back to the
origin of the term gene and I didn't
know this until about six months ago uh
it was originally proposed by this
Danish geneticist and this is not the
original Danish this was a translation
to German I know just enough German to
find the right sentence to have pasted
into google translate the word gene is
completely free of any hypothesis it
only expresses the assured fact that at
any rate many characteristics of the
organism are contingent vais special
separable and therefore self-existent
fundamentals that occur in the game
meats so genes are the things in the
genome that actually control the
characteristics of the organism and I'm
gonna argue yeah not all gene models are
going to correspond to genes so one of
the wonderful things about the grasses
is that they have very conservative
synteny so Sydney is the conservation of
the same genes in the same order so
you're seeing here's a graphic from from
Koji which is an online comparative
genomics tool it's run by Eric Lyons at
University of Arizona and each of these
we have a nice gene model comparing a
region in rice in foxtail millet in
sorghum and in maize and these are red
orange boxes are regions of homologous
sequence identified blasts and what you
can see is that we have some of the same
genes in the same order there's also a
tandem duplication in the sorghum so we
have two copies of this particular gene
I think this might be phytochrome be I'd
have to check on that
so we have these genes that are dream
models that are conserved at the same
locations across Halle grasses we also
have lots of gene models that are not
conserved at the same locations and
different grasses so these are synthetic
ornithologist genes these are non
synthetic genes and the fact that we see
them here but not another species means
that they inserted into their present
location in the genome
since the divergence of these different
species so if we look at the genes that
actually have known characterized
functions so some geneticists walk
through a field they said that plant is
so interestingly weird I'm going to
spend those five years of my life
figuring out what is the gene
responsible for why that plant looks
weird those genes are eight times as
likely to be these conserved some Tanic
genes as the non conserved that the non
synthetic genes which are evolutionarily
more recent and may or may not have
functions now there's also an argument
who made that maybe these non setting
genes are involved in processes that
aren't as immediately obvious as you
walk through the field there was at
least one exception where that is the
case which is if you look at disease for
systems genes these are almost always
the come from the non satanic fraction
of the genome but a lot of these genes
do appear to be sequences with a
potential to code for protein or that
actually do code for protein but they're
in search of a functional role still and
there are lots of other ways that you
can see differences between the
conserved synthetic genes so they tend
to have very different methylation
profiles the listen chemically conserved
genes the non synthetic genes tend to
look a lot like intergenic sequence
synthetic genes are expressed at higher
levels this is from a Wally paper a
couple years ago but more interesting to
me if you look at non-synthetic genes
which are expressed
they make significant amounts of mRNA
they're much less likely to have that
mRNAs translated into protein than the
conserved sent ending genes so if there
this would be very consistent with them
having fewer phenotypic consequences
because even though there are ways to
produce unity the consequences without
making a protein it's a lot easier to
have a phenotype if you if you do make a
protein
so given a lot of these differences we
put together just a very simple PCA
analysis so what you see here is a 2d
anyway you're seeing essentially a
kernel density plot of both all the
annotated gene models in maize and red
here and these gold standard genes that
have been identified based on a forward
genetic Linotype and this is a subset of
the trait we've put about a dozen traits
into this basic PC based on ones we knew
that there were significant differences
between genes with known phenotypes and
those without and we see that there's a
relatively large separation so a lot of
the annotated genes in the maize genome
are concentrated over here they're more
likely to show presence absence
variation they're less likely to be
aesthetically conserved they're less
likely to show evidence of being
translated into protein but the genes
with no in phenotypes and a cluster over
on the side of the distribution so with
this I'm going to give you a few
takeaways from this very broad idea
which is that we really do need to
remember that gene models are hypotheses
so our gene model is hypothesis that
this particular portion of the genome is
actually a gene it actually plays a role
in determining the phenotype of an
organism and I've been very guilty of
this myself that I sort of treat all
gene models as equally likely to cause
phenotypes and that that's not true and
we would treat that any other kind of
hypothesis the same way there are some
hypotheses they're more like to be true
some that are less likely to be true the
ones that you know seem very unexpected
but then I end up being consistent of
observation are really really exciting
but we can do a lot to prioritize which
hypotheses that make sense to test which
hypotheses you spend a lot of time
studying I think we do a lot better job
of this with gene models as well I'm
going to come back to that at the very
end of the talk but now to jump a little
bit from very broad how do we identify
the genes likely to have any phenotypic
consequence to linking specific genes to
specific phenotypes now it was I was
funny I was meeting with some folks and
and that's lab yesterday and they had
reconstructed almost this exact same
slide I think probably everyone working
in Hydra phenotyping has a version of
this
which is that genotyping has gone from
extraordinarily expensive to essentially
a trivial part of the cost
honestly collecting the samples and
doing the DNA extractions may cost more
at this point when you factor in the
labor phenotyping on the other hand has
not gotten substantially cheaper
anything that's probably gone up because
the cost of human labour perfectly
skilled human labor is going up faster
than inflation high throughput
phenotyping is a reaction to the
recognition of this imbalance between
the decreasing cost of genotyping and
the constant or increasing cost of
phenotyping it's also an interesting
concept because it's really there's not
a good definition of phenotyping it's
defined by what it's not so high through
phenotyping is not driving a combine
through the field and getting yield and
it is not sending a bunch of students
into the field with protractors and
rollers and notebooks to write things
down because the students who are
willing to do that we're willing to go
out in a cornfield or a sorghum field in
the middle of summer here in Ithaca and
Nebraska they're a very limited pool I
don't think we can really grow that for
very much they're a non-renewable
resource so if we want to get more data
we need other strategies but as long as
you're not and either of those two
things you can say that you're - you
know type as long as you're measuring
something about plants so it's alright
now we want to invest a lot in hydric
phenotyping it's really not clear what
it is so I'm going to walk you through
the the three three major steps or three
major bottlenecks we found in terms of
actually using this to do something
useful to understand how plants work so
we have a little flow chart here yeah
three transitions so growing plants I do
know how to do that I'm not great at it
I kill them occasionally but we can grow
plants and we can collect rates from
them but the first challenge is an
engineering challenge which is once you
have all these plants how do you collect
new and interesting kinds of data from
them other than having somebody out
there with a notebook and so this is an
engineering challenge in dementia day
I'm fortunate to work with this engineer
got University Nebraska so we both have
this field based system Frank is a
former postdoc and any funds lab who's
now on staff just to keep this field
based system up and running where we
have a
a large payload that can move back and
forth throughout the field and we can
send up both heavier and more expensive
instruments on this than we could on a
drone because we don't have to worry
about it crashing or veering off or
anything like that the other system
which came online about the same time I
was hired at University Nebraska is just
one of these conveyor belt' greenhouses
some of you may have visited Danforth or
Pioneer so you've seen these the thing
that sets Nebraska's apart from other
people's is not that we can grow more
plants now that we're cheaper widths
it's really expensive to run but the
fact that we can grow plants to such a
large size so with this facility can
grow plants up to about 2.3 meters and
still move them through here and have
them imaged with a series of cameras
every day collects weights and the
specific amount of water being used by
each plant in each day so that's enough
to grow grain types or gums all the way
to maturity it's enough to grow some but
not all maize inbreds Torture t if you
try and grow maize hybrids on this they
get above that 2.3 meter threshold and
start hitting into the ceiling as they
go through and plants toppling over and
that's not very much fun and then it
turns out the greenhouse staff have to D
Tassel your plants so they can still
move through the system at which point I
would argue there's not a lot of useful
quantitative data but what you get out
of this is a series of different imaging
types so you see here is one plant being
imaged on one day so we have an RGB
camera the plant is photographed from
different angles around about a 180
degree arc we also have a thermal IR
camera you'll notice that the plant is
about the same color as the background
that's because originally these plants
sat in the dark for about 10 minutes
before they were imaged at which point
they equilibria with Airy temperature
we've now fixed this by having a tunnel
where they're under high light and
exposed to the same heat and air
conditions is in the greenhouse before
their image fluorescence camera which
I'm not going to talk about very much
today in a hyperspectral camera which I
am so the hype is you know in the human
eye we have three different cones to
receive different wavelengths of light
the hyperspectral camera in this case is
perceiving 243 distinct wavelengths of
light so there are lots of colors that
are going to look the same to your eye
or mine that can be distinguished with
this camera
so we have lots and lots of data on I'm
working with great engineers to collect
the data but there's a step that I think
is underappreciated probably you folks
to appreciate this but when you talk to
people outside of the plant biology
community it's very hard to QTL mapping
or gee wasps or anything on a bunch of
pictures I've actually seen people
propose ways to do that a little bit but
really what we need is a giant
spreadsheet of numerical measurements of
something we care about the plate about
with the plant and that becomes a
computer vision or a machine learning
challenge how do we go with pictures or
a lie to our point clouds or
hyperspectral data cubes and actually
measure things we care about the planet
and there are a lot of approaches to
that but I'm going to tell you about a
couple things going on in my lab that I
think are very interesting so one
approach is to use neural nets so you
give the computer lots and lots of
pictures with known traits and it will
learn from that how to score new
pictures the challenge we have is that
even though we have all these hyper
phenotyping facilities actually getting
enough training data to train a neural
map can be challenging so this is work
actually but an undergrad in my lab Tom
Hoban who took software that was
originally designed to make 3d models of
plants for video games and use this to
create models of corn plants which he
concerned into a semi accurate
replication of the same chamber we were
collecting real plants from so in a
matter of about eight hours he could
make about 26,000 of these synthetic
corn plants with different parameters
and known 3d structures we worked out
what it would have cost to grow these on
the actual phenotyping facility it was
about $80,000 worth of data and we can
use these simulated images to train a
computer to predict real images what
you're looking at here is prediction of
leaf counting so this is the correlation
if you just show pictures to two
different people and have them count the
number of leaves on the corn plant the
correlation is about point nine so it's
good but it's not perfect that's the
first thing to recognize is we're not
going to get a perfect correlation
because we can't get perfect correlation
between different human beings so our
goal is 0.9 we're not able to get there
what this is showing and I will walk you
through in too much detail is that when
data is very scarce so about 300 images
or class or less addy and the synthetic
data actually improves our accuracy over
just using the real images and these are
not particularly accurate
representations of a corn plant I mean I
think it's I hope it's recognizably a
corn plant there's clearly a lot more we
could do to make this look more like a
corn plant and so increase the
usefulness of simulated data so that's
that's one approach to teaching
computers how to measure things from
images another is those taking advantage
of things like hyperspectral cameras
which perceive the world in very
different ways the way a human being
does so you see here is a hyperspectral
data cube from a particular store gun
plant oh this is work from Alejandro
Paige's who is a computer science
undergraduate in the lab and so what he
did is he took a bunch of these images
put them up on a web tool called
Zooniverse which is a citizen science
tool so a lot of this if you go on the
website it's like game cameras in Africa
and you know how are there zebras the
images how many zebra is that sort of
thing but we put up all these sorghum
plants just ask people to say ok where
are the stems where the leaves where the
panels and miraculously some people were
willing to do that even given the option
looking cool zebras and dress so we very
rapidly got a training dataset of about
8,000 data points each of which is one
pixel within each pixel we have 243
different wavelengths intensities
looking at that we can develop very
separate reflectance parameters or what
these different classes and pixels look
like leaf the stalk now as a human being
it's very easy to look at a standard
text picture of a sorghum plant and tell
me where is the belief where's the stem
where's the pentacle it turned out to be
a very challenging problem for the
computer to do that from the RGB image
but with the hyperspectral data computer
can do a very good job of separating
these different classes one of the
things I think is actually cool is it
does make mistakes and you can see what
it's doing is it thinks that the mid
ribs of the sorghum leaves our stem so
you have this dense lignified tissue and
that's that's getting misclassified so
even the mistakes are things that make
sense I'm gonna come back to that Oh
so the nice thing about being able to
separate out the different parts of the
sorghum plant is we can start to measure
traits that make more sense biologically
so one of the first things whenever our
students join the lab is they learn how
to segment out just this is an RGB
photos of corn of sorghum plants and
we've this is actually the same sort of
plant over time and the image is
segmented so we have the plant pixels
circled in red you can see there's some
mistakes down here but it's possible to
measure the whole height of the plant
what you will note is that the height of
the whole plant goes up and then goes
down because as the flag leaf first
comes up it's pointing straight up and
then as the panicle starts to emerge
that angle of that leaf changes so we
get this sort of bump in the analysis by
having this organ aware segmentation we
can extend instead look at the same
chord same sorghum plant and look at
just the height of the stammen panicle
and so we get a much more consistent
growth curve that is reflected doing a
better job of reflecting how the plant
is growing then looking at the the total
height which is influenced just by this
leaf sort of flapping up and down as the
plant grows and this is important
because when you look at a lot of traits
that are measured hyperspectral are from
high people phenotyping data you'll get
a something like this so these are two
traits just plant height and biomass and
here we've got ground truth which was
measured again by students with rollers
and notebooks and scales and this is the
estimated measurements for both of these
from the images and these correlations
look pretty good this is a question that
my student Jakaya thought to ask though
is the error that's left here is it
random if it's random error we'll just
throw more plants that it will get
really good accurate estimates or is it
systematic and what he found was that it
was systematic so there were certain
genotypes that were systematically
having their biomass under predicted and
others that were systematically having
their biomass over predicted so about
half of that variation is heritable it's
controlled by genetics so there are
differences in the architecture of the
plant that are producing systematic
errors in our measurements so if we were
using this to
you say train of genomic prediction
model for biomass we wouldn't just be
predicting biomass we'd also be
predicting the phenotypes that lead to
errors in measurement of biomass from -
phenotyping data so it is important if
we can get getting more accuracy is very
important not just because it's more
accuracy - so removing systematic biases
in the way that the data is being
collected so now to the fun bit so we've
gone from growing plants we've developed
robots and sensors and things to collect
data and computer algorithms to turn all
that data into giant spreadsheets full
of numbers but I really am a biologist
at heart I would like to actually you
know map some genes or find something
and there are some interesting
quantitative genetics challenges
opportunities whatever you want to call
them that occur because of the types of
data that are produced by a community I
think so this is the same sort implanted
last section you can see the two
different measurements of height you can
also see the the heritability of height
as measured by these two methods both
from the individual data points and also
fitting a non parametric curve to each
of the heights and you can see that
generally the heritability from the
fitted curve is a little bit higher than
from the raw data it's not a perfect
pattern and we think this is because
we're able to borrow data from adjacent
peda points to get a more accurate
measurement so another student my lab
Chen yung yau is working on using this
to do mapping in the sorghum Association
panel which is a population about 400
sorghum wines most of which are
conversion lines so they were collected
from all over the world cross to us germ
plasm to degress both photo period and
sensitivity dreams will actually flower
if we grow them in the summer and
Nebraska and also working genes so that
they will be plants like this and not
plants taller than the ceiling now if
you grow this population in the field
and you're interested in plant height
it's very easy to map a couple two of
the at least two maybe three of the
large effect genes that are involved in
sargam height because there are still
some very very
also our compliance in our population
now I mentioned in the greenhouse we can
only grow up plants to about 2.3 meters
so we take out the extremely tall plants
that are producing a strong signal and
use the same data we now are not able to
map any of the these dwarfing genes we
know they're real you know where they
are you know we can't find them with the
population we're gonna work with so you
see here is our the high curves a large
number of the different sorghum plants
collected from this experiment in the
greenhouse whistles days after planting
this is the height in centimeters and
you can see that when the plant gets
ready to have the pentacle emerge you
have this large bolting response which
happens at different times for different
plants and it just looks very very messy
and it's not quite clear what to do with
it this is actually pearl millet not
sorghum because it looks cooler but
you're seeing images I think these were
collected every two days of this promo
plant throughout its lifecycle as a
human being it's very easy to look at
this plant and see oh look there's this
transition it goes from just making
leaves now it has some panicles at the
top and then it goes into senescence you
will also notice that there's this
person who comes in was collecting was
doing some sort of maintenance during
one of the days while we were like the
images again this is a thing that is
easy for a human to do but genuine was
able to train a neural net using less
than a thousand images to get relatively
good accuracy at identifying when is
this transition point from reproductive
development to reap vegetative
development to reproductive development
again is that even the errors are the
kinds of errors that human might make so
the transition point we're targeting is
when does the pentacle first become
visible so the computer there's a little
bit of Pinnacle shooting out here the
computer misclassified this is not
flowering this plant is about to flower
the panicles right here in the stem
you've got the flag leaf up here and the
computer not confused inside this was a
farm plant so these are a lot of the
same kinds of mistakes that I would
expect particularly a board human being
to make if I was you know hiring high
school students or people online or
something
these classifications so once we have
this classification data instead of
using planting as our benchmark for
comparing everything we can shift the
data around two days before a pentacle
immersions and we start to get much more
similar shapes of growth what you'll
notice is now we have different
different time ranges measured for each
plant
and with this the first thing we can do
is just scan through and do genome-wide
Association study or height on every
different day see okay so this is Z
dwarf - and group won't work or if to
work for which i think is not actually
work for I think that's labeled show up
and then later on in development we go
so that's animated it's a little hard to
follow so here's another way of
displaying the same data so you see here
on the y-axis is the ten chromosomes of
sorghum and going across we've
highlighted genomic fins when there's at
least one significant step in that day
of the analysis and there are several
relatively long Peaks that correspond to
some of the genes that we would expect
to be able to map either if we benchmark
on days after planting or working the
benchmark and days at emergence we're
writing lots and lots of us here and if
I tell you where the known genes are we
can find them but it would be it's hard
for me to look at this and say what
conference okay we really have
identified we want identify there's a
lot of noise also down in the analysis
so this is where we started talking to
another statistician at the University
of Nebraska you Honshu who was a recent
hire and his expertise is on working
with nonparametric regression and the
curves you can generate from that and
actually me although how do you break
that down into how different individuals
vary with respect to those those curves
so you see here in gray are all the
curves for all of the sorghum plants in
our population as well as both the
empirical estimate of sort of the center
value or the average pattern and the
estimated pattern from his nonparametric
regression and he can then do a
functional principal component analysis
to identify what are the major
components of variation which is what
you see on the other side of this slide
so pc1 which explains about two-thirds
of the variance is essentially just
taller versus shorter so I never really
understand what what determines what's
plus and what's - but you can see if you
have a more negative value for PC one
the plant is taller essentially
throughout development you have a more
positive value at shorter PC two on the
other hand is essentially a trade off so
you have and this explains another like
twenty to thirty percent I'm gonna have
it on all later slide where you're
taller earlier and shorter later so now
for every plant we can describe the
curb as a combination of four principle
components these to explain most of the
variation and we can do G wasjust using
these principle components that describe
the shape of the curve as our our
metrics instead and when we do that we
get some very clean signals so okay 68%
of 20 years work one dwarf two are both
identified the principal component one
and Dwarf three or component two now
what's interesting about this is you
know a little bit about the biology of
how these different genes affects plant
height so dwarf one dwarf to affect
essentially all the internodes were
three is affecting the lower internodes
but not the elongation of the peduncle
so the the stand that leads up to the
panicle so what you'd expect here is
this would have a substantial effect on
height before flower but then you
wouldn't can they run em again a
backwards anyway I'm not gonna dig
myself a deeper hole in this slide what
I'm gonna say is that the effect height
differently and it's consistent with the
patterns with the PCs and I will defer
to qionghua my student on why that all
makes sense all right so the yeah we can
we can integrate data across multiple
time points and we're able to recover
statistical power to identify genes that
we know are there because we can
identify them in a larger population by
integrating this time series data people
have done this previously using
parametric models where you decide okay
plants are going to grow and show a log
my logarithmic pattern of grow what we
found here was not actually that
different from logarithmic patterns but
what I like about it is it doesn't force
that assumption so a lot of the really
interesting stuff in biology is they're
really weird unexpected stuff and non
parametric curve fitting can capture
weird unexpected stuff whereas fitting
the sigmoidal curves cannot
Otto Tate of genetics point I want to
talk about is the challenge of high
dimensional or nearly high dimensional
data so technically I'm told by my
status different collaborators I cannot
call it high dimensional until I've
measured more phenotypes than the number
of individuals in my population which is
a high bar so we're this here I'm going
to talk about having hundreds of
phenotypes whether or not it is a truly
high dimensional data set now that
because of both types of you know typing
and large collaborative projects
becoming more and more common to have
many many traits towards the same
population in plant biology we also see
this from medical data record mining in
humans and also from large numbers of
molecular phenotypes so looking at
hundreds of metabolites or thousands of
gene expression levels across all
populations and so this presents a
challenge of multiple testing because
the conventional approach to doing this
would be to do set to G wasps for every
single trait and this becomes
combinatorially or common becomes a lot
of tests very very fast so a student my
lab jukai lang working with a
statistician at Iowa State was
interested in trying some other methods
to deal with this data and the data set
we used was was from here at Cornell
with the Amaze 282 Association panel and
so you can see that there were a large
numbers of traits measured and many of
those traits were scored enough to
sixteen different environments so we had
a whole total of 260 trade data sets to
work with
and the challenge of this so if we do G
Waze for any one trait so what you're
seeing here is G us for a single snip in
a single gene and instead of having all
the steps in the x-axis each of these
represents the significance for one of
the traits in the data set so if I run
any as US for one of these these are
flowering time traits a lot of them are
statistically significant on their own
if we take into account all the
hypotheses that are being tested across
all of the phenotypes
none of them are significant anymore so
we would like to be able to do some sort
of a more integrated test to utilize the
data from all these traits together
because clearly if you're detecting the
signal and many many different
measurements of the the phenotype that
should we should be able to sort of
combine and leverage that signal see the
approach used here is first to identify
sets of gene sets of steps within a gene
to cluster and then select a single
representative snip for groups of
markers that are in high LD with each
other the first half of this model is
just looking at multiple snips but a
single phenotype and is fitting a very
complicated just to model which I will
be upfront is essentially a black box to
me my status to sickle collaborator and
then test that the results that come out
make sense go through a stepwise
selection procedure to select subsets of
all the the phenotypes that show a
significant signal for that gene do a
new comparison between our initial model
which is attempting to explain the
variation for all the snips within that
gene we've kept after filtering using
both principal components population
structure variation as well as a
selected subset of the traits from the
whole new hundred sixteen set I'll say
so there's a preprint that will go into
the methodology here in a lot more
detail we also have the R code that was
used up on on github
stepwise selection procedure worse there
are essentially really large numbers of
hypotheses that are being tested so the
p-value distribution we see is quite
skewed relative to what we would expect
from the number of tests where we're
actually running in terms instead of
implicitly running its weight of doing a
lot of permutation testing just to
determine what what is the distribution
of p-values we would expect to see
because they end up being very extreme
anyway and from this we can establish
what we hope is an accurate false
discovery rate cut off and doing this
takes quite a bit of time we had to make
even making some some compromises and so
there are things we know we could be
doing better that we're not because it
still takes about seven years of CPU
time to analyze 32,000 gene models a
maze and then we get results others also
look like this so I already talked you
through on the top we have each
phenotype scored here along the the
x-axis on the top you have the p-values
for the individual phenotypes on the
second side you have either the selected
phenotypes for non selected phenotypes
or this gene and then an overall
significance score for the gene as a
whole whether we see a significant so XI
a ssin between these snips in this gene
and all the phenotypes measured or this
population as I think probably came
across the way I explain this a lot of
the stats I don't understand the details
up so I want to see whether or not the
associations that are identified by this
model make any sense at all fortunately
we have a couple of ways to do that
so the first is looking at overlap
between the genes that are identified in
this population with this set of data in
this method and genes that were
identified in different populations
using different methods so here we're
comparing the genes that were identified
by a number of different models in the
282 population two genes that were
identified in the nested Association
mapping population which shares some of
the same haplotypes there's a larger and
with different structure now I talked to
Ed yesterday and there may be some
problems with this analysis and we're
gonna work on a way to validate it
but in principle anyway if we have more
accuracy we should see more overlap
between the genes we identify our
population and the genes identified in a
different population for some of the
same phenotypes then the genes
identified by conventional algorithms so
you see here we have some data on
version 2 of the maze genome and some
one version 4 so we're constrained to
only the genes that actually have
one-to-one correspondence between the
two versions of the genome about 14
percent of those genes were identified
as linked to phenotypes the nest of
Association mapping population then we
can look at the subsets of genes
identified by different she wants
algorithms and they are enriched so
they're more like the genes identified
in the Association the 282 Association
populations are more likely to also been
identified ministers Association mapping
population so that's good that's what we
expected and then this genome-wide
phenome wine analysis that my students
if I came up with we see substantially
higher overlap but is significantly
higher than the overlaps scene-by-scene
with any of the conventional G wass
methods this is the internal control
here so this is multiple step a single
trait so it is utilizing multiple
markers within the gene but not trying
to do the selection picking a subset of
traits to test together we can also look
at the kinds of genes that are being
identified by the the GP loss model
compared to conventional G loss
oh you're seeing here is a go enrichment
analysis so we went identifying
essentially the same number of genes we
see much more enrichment of a wide range
of go term enrichment and purification
of go terms in the GPS genes that
relative to genes identified by G wasps
on the same underlying phenotypic and
genotypic data so I'm not gonna go into
this too much but I'm just going to
assert that this demonstrates that we at
least are identifying a less random
subset of the genome which could be a
good or a bad thing
we can also look at the specific
phenotypes that are being identified as
associated with individual genes that
have been characterized through for
genetics so this is an example of
anterior one which is classical mutants
cloned back in 95 95 so we know a lot
about phenotypes that the mutants of
this gene exhibit we also know the
phenotypes that were identified is
associated with it based on the the GP
wasps model and a lot of these match up
not all of them so that gives us some
sort of qualitative degree of confidence
the thing that I think is is most
exciting about the genes identified by
this method though it's not any of these
but the the feature the ways that they
are different from the average gene in
the genome so we're gonna compare here
we have all the genes our conventional G
wasps GP wants genes and other control
which are a set of these classical
mutants which again are those genes that
somebody walked through a field and said
that phenotype is so interesting I need
to clone it so you can see that if we
just look at a having an averaged
expression level higher than a single FP
can all of these sets are much more
likely to be expressed at at levels
above background than the overall set of
gene models in the genome if we look at
kak F so a measure of how effectively
purifying selection is operating on
these you only do this for the subset of
genes that are actually conserved in
sorting we see that both the classical
mutants and the GPS genes have a shift a
statistically significant shift to
distribution towards lower KS ratios
which indicates they're subject to
stronger purifying selection and the
average gene in the genome ah there a
couple of other markers I told you about
synthetic conservation which is a almost
all of the classical mutants are these
synthetically conserved genes and this
particular set about ninety four of them
we also see a substantial enrichment
both for genes identified by
conventional G wasps and for IGP wasps
relative to the background set and
conversely amazed there are a lot of
genes to exhibit presence absence
variations so they're in b73 se but
they're
absent from other genetic backgrounds
and we see that I was quite common for
the genes that as a whole it is much
rarer for genes identified through
quantitative genetics and GP wasps is
closer to the really low level that we
see for classical mutants so any
quantitative genetics approach to
identifying genes that are associated in
phenotype identifies genes that look
more like classical mutants than the
overall population of gene models and
the approach that GK is using seems to
identify a population looks even more
like those classical mutants than
conventional Jie wasps so to summarize
we identify we're identifying this
population of genes that we think are
associated with phenotypic variation
there more broadly expressed there more
conserved at the same positions across
species less likely to exhibit
presence/absence variation they also to
be longer genes which we see also for
the classical mutants and so we can take
this figure that I showed you at the
beginning of the presentation and we can
calculate essentially a gene function
soy which is just the inverse of that
principal component one so a score over
here means you look more like a
classical mutant score over here means
you look more alike the gene models that
don't look like classical music see the
distribution of all the gene models
their genome has a large peak over here
and both the classical mutants and the
GPS genes exhibit similar distributions
shifted towards this end of the spectrum
so the beginning of this talk I told you
that I think we can do a bit much better
job of deciding which gene models
represent hypotheses that likely are
valid that they likely do explain
something about how the genome
determines the characteristics of an
organism in which which gene models are
much less likely to play a significant
role in determining phenotype as a whole
and while I have some students who are
working on doing much better jobs of
this prediction than what I have right
now I hope this is at least convinced
you that such a thing is possible that
we really can look at gene models to do
a better job of saying you know these
probably are interesting and worthy a
lot of a lot more study these probably
we don't want to burnout grad students
trying to find a phenotype so with that
I would like to thank my my wonderful
my colleagues both engineering
statistics and biology and all of you
for your attention here today I'd be
happy to take any questions
[Applause]
they've already funded price that's a
very good question
um so that mean I don't have a perfect
answer I would say because we're using
primarily genes that were identified
prior to 2011 I think the benefit of
being cloned in rice which much smaller
because a lot of that happened before we
had a maize genome to me compared to if
we it would be really interesting I've
got a student working on getting the
2011 to 2019 genes I would predict we'd
see a bigger effect of already having a
characterized function in rice or
another grass in that later so you could
compile a species genes that are highly
expressed also actively expressed and so
in this model which tries to predict
gene studies of a range of these that's
a very good question let me go yeah so
the question was that you observed a lot
of correlation over already between the
the average level of expression the
breadth of expression across many
different tissues the KS which
is not in this particular model cuz only
we only had it for some technically
conserved genes and there was another
one oh okay so we certainly see yeah
that's one of the things I like about
being able to visualize the data this
way is we do see a lot of these do seem
to show up similarly when we project
them into the PCA space I think that
there are some genes though we see that
you have very high expression that are
not evolutionarily conserved and so
being able to pull out some of them in
the categories that are exceptions to
the overall trend and look at those
would be be very interesting in terms of
figuring out whether the reason a lot of
these are showing up is that they're all
correlated say with expression or
whether they have separate predictive
power I haven't done that yet I would be
interested to find out the answer and
share it with you so that's a good
question so we can we can configure how
flexible it's going to be with
individual data points one of the things
I really like about it though is it does
tolerate uneven data so if we have dense
sampling in some parts and much less
dense in other parts we're still able to
fit reasonably good curves one of the
points I didn't talk about a lot with
this is the way that the images are
collected we actually can grow twice as
many plants as it can be photographed in
a day so the only reason we're able to
make this comparison is because we're
able to use the nonparametric regression
to fill in the values so that we can
look at the whole population at the same
time yes as far as the county leaves the
sort of plants and simulated images
what's them assuming you have a computer
during corn and then just we're just
taking more pictures of the same more
peeps of the same plants because both
leads is I mean maybe County leaves is
simple enough for not overfitting
but isolated I would like just take more
pictures with the same training course
so there are a number vague mentation
approaches
you can use with real images you can you
know mirror the image and then do a
adding noise I think that we would
rapidly hit a point of diminishing
returns in terms of the number of
different angles you can photograph the
plant from and still get noticeably
different images so what I like about
the simulated approach and I haven't
shown that this is the case is that in
principle we're simpler sampling a
really wide parameter space in terms of
what a corn plant looks like and in some
ways that's a problem so I'm not gonna
jump all the way back to that slide but
one of the issues we had is we don't
actually have an alternating pilot taxi
in the simulated plants the guy who made
the the corn plant model for video games
I don't think realize that that was did
so we we could do more work to converge
on a biologic and form 3d model the
bigger challenge
and it's not such an issue for relief
counting is you also need the you don't
just need the photos you need the ground
truth and so for a lot of sort of
complex structural traits it can be very
challenging to collect the ground truth
from large numbers of real plants you
have the full 3d model of the corn plant
you already know all the ground truth so
it's not just collecting the images but
collecting the ground truth where you
save effort so there are about a hundred
genes and so these are ones that were
identified first by phenotype and then
somebody actually cloned it that way
rather than either just a statistical
association between the gene and
phenotype or reverse genetics if
somebody said hey this gene looks
interesting let's knock it out and then
try really hard to find a phenotype
you've been concentrating a lot on the
morphological tannin times yes and maybe
a bunch of this within pertains to those
because historically that's what people
mapped and those in the genes that work
alone first
what about when you start looking at
physiological traits and things that
aren't most logically observable in this
way wouldn't that shift the entire gene
space that you're working with that is a
good question so as I mentioned
certainly for the disease resistance
genes those behaved so differently from
everything else in terms of the stuff
involved in physiology or biochemistry
that isn't reflected in morphology I'm
not sure I could make a good prediction
right now but the great thing is we're
getting those datasets you know more and
more every day so I'm so very soon I'm
confident I would have an answer on
whether they would behave the same as
the Norfolk genes controlling
morphological traits or if they show
very different trying to think about the
transcription factors that do such
different things in different species
and I mean my take-home is a lot of what
is regulated at least the things that
we've been interested in are regulated
by transcription factors and they're
there Abe expressed often at very low
levels and be very specific times and
tissues and see they affect the kinds of
phenotypes were interested in but the
same transcription factor does
completely opposite things or different
things in different species so that's
why I'm you know I'm just trying to I
think that's a reach into the gene space
that I'm yeah I'm interested in that I
don't know of this I yeah I would agree
I don't we it's not answered but the
datasets are out there so I need to get
you an answer
thank you yeah quick question yeah
I really like your models that separate
leaves from stocks from vehicles those
results look really nice I'm wondering
whether the weights for those models as
is generalize well to other grasses that
you have similar data sets for I'm I'm
actually that's one of the things I'm
sure Young's to-do list is to run this
we have cro millet maize data and see
whether it's translatable or if we need
a new training set for each species that
we work on they do work very well across
the 400 sorghum genotypes so at least
it's not genotype specific which is
always the this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at Cornell
edu